Yes, you're right.
You cannot wash eggs and put them on this rack.
If you wash the.
The eggs,
the protected bloom that's on top of the eggs gets washed away.
Now, chicken eggs have thousands of pores.
So if you wash the bloom off,
which is protecting the pores,
um, bacteria gets inside.
So, yeah,
you can leave a washed egg on the counter for a few days,
but anything after that,
the egg will start to rot.
So the key to this is to keep your chicken coop clean,
so then you get clean eggs.
Now, that doesn't mean I clean my chicken coop often.
I barely clean this thing,
but I have it set up in a way that my eggs don't get dirty.
Right now, we actually needs cleaning
because they like to sit out here and people over the next box.
But inside,
I use a sand bedding,
which you can see.
I do actually need to sweep the poop.
It's been like that for a few weeks.
And the nest boxes are over here.
The key to a successful setup is to have your perches
higher than your nest boxes.
If they're not higher than your nest boxes,
your chickens will perch in your nest boxes and shit in there,
and then you have shit on your egg.